que vous avez été obligé d'attendre si
longtemps
mais nous avons eu une discussion assez
compliquée probablement la première
discussion assez sincère pour faire la
révision de tous les problèmes qui sont
liés à la réalisation des accords de
disques et la réalisation de conflit on
s'est mis d'accord que indépendamment
des divergences liées aux accords de
mise contre le kremlin et les
républiques et des régions de donetsk de
lougansk le cessez le feu doit être
respectée sans conditions surtout le
traité du 22 juillet 2020 doit être
respectée à tout près par les deux
parties de se prêter à ce que c'est
l'obligation qui incombe
aux troupes et aux forces armées
ukrainiennes et de certaines régions de
donetsk de lougansk ce qui est écrit
dans les accords de minsk
c'est un sujet c'est vraiment le coeur
du sujet dont nous avons discuté
aujourd'hui en ce qui concerne d'autres
questions
nous avons fait la revue
de ces différentes interprétations de
ces accords de minsk est il qu'ils
existent et on se met d'accord de
continuer des consultations internes en
ukraine et d'autres participants deux
formats normandie pour que nous
puissions nous revoir dans quinze jours
à berlin pour trouver vraiment les
résolution de tous les problèmes qui
malheureusement continue à persister
pendant les sept dernières années qui
sont toujours pas résolus
la responsabilité c'est ça qui a été en
fait
nous tous on s'est mis d'accord que
c'est vraiment une percée
sur le fait que pendant qu'il ya
toujours des divergences
d'interprétation
des accords de mise surtout leur mise en
place et le respect le format ne mendie
ne pourrait pas jouer un rôle s'ils
finissent yéti fait
en ce qui concerne la résolution de
conflits en ukraine c'est vraiment la
tâche primordiale au format normandise
trouver la seule interprétation et
compréhension des accords de minsk
surtout les conditions politiques le
respect du cessez le feu
surtout les questions humanitaires qui
quoi et qu'est-ce qui doit très
respectées pour éviter les divergences
les divergences pendant qu'il persiste
nous pourrons nous pourrions pas envoyé
des signaux positifs au groupe de
contact
dans le but de favoriser la résolution
de ce conflit et nous avons toujours
continué à
suivre cet hymne nos collègues l'ont
accepté et on s'y met d'accord de
continuer à
mener ces discussions pour trouver les
résolutions de tous ces divergences qui
sont nombreuses malheureusement jusqu'à
présent et nous espérons que les
résultats de cet accord
serait mise en place dans 15 jours nous
ne puissions rapprocher l'imposition
et pour que nous puissions faire part de
recommandations dans le cadre du
processus de discussions pour parler
d'un mise pour que le cren
donetsk donbass puis ça vous des
solutions de ce conflit parce que le
format normandie n'a pas de pouvoir n'a
pas de compétence dans la résolution de
ce conflit parce que le format normandie
ne pourrait que donner des
recommandations en estimant les
positions des parties de ce conflit
parce que c'est toujours notre position
intacte qui changent pas qui serait
vraiment le coeur de nos futures
discussions
c'est vraiment le bilan
complet de nos discussions qui ont duré
pendant huit heures qui prennent à des
prêts à denis pages de texte est écrit
sur toutes les recommandations les
commentaires que j'aurais dû vous
présenter maintenant je suis prêt à
répondre à vos questions
chers collègues j'ai une seule du monde
je me demande de bien formuler vos
questions pour qu'elle soit brève
malheureusement nous n'avons que peu de
temps
à la chesnaie rossiya
ma question et telles que comment quant
à vous a changé la position des gants
européens et dont la france dans la
question clé sur la nécessité de
dialogue direct entre donner cependant
ce qui est contenu de cette
correspondance diplomatique et qui a
prouvé que les français n'étaient pas
prêts à soutenir ce point une très bonne
question tout précise vraiment direct
je pense que c'est une question clé qui
n'a pas toujours été résolus pendant les
sept dernières années
parce que tout d'abord pour définir les
positions des deux parties c'est pour ça
que nos collègues ont demandé la pause
de quinze jours
et aujourd'hui ne
parlons plus tôt non seulement juste de
la discussion de la question et surtout
non seulement d'un dialogue et physique
les gens les yeux dans les yeux parce
que surtout les propositions écrites de
nombreuses propositions qui ont été
présentés par le donbass au niveau du
groupe de contact pour qu'on puisse au
moins avoir un contact et réponse c'est
positif au négatif parce que même déjà
pour cette question s'est pas mis
d'accord c'est pour ça que nos collègues
ont demandé la pause de quinze jours
malheureusement toutes les propositions
soumises par certains représentants de
différentes régions de l'ukraine surtout
pour les questions politiques au cren
de sécurité une manière non non pas de
réaction au moins positives ou négatives
de la part craignait
surtout en ce qui concerne la sa propre
vision des conditions politiques de la
régularisation de ce conflit l'autonomie
statut particulier un mot des
particuliers ce qui est écrit dans les
accords de misc l'ukraine s'est jamais
prononcé sur toutes ces questions
nous allons espérer que pendant les 15
jours à venir les collègues auraient
comprendre surtout l'allemagne et la
france et les représentants de l'ukraine
nés et qu'ils ont assisté ces
négociations ils ont compris que sans
trancher cette question nous n'allons
pas avancer parce que c'est ton
depuis le 9 mars 2015
à ce sujet parce que le 9 mars 2015 le
dialogue à ce sujet aurait dû commencer
mais on la met jamais même pas entamé
malgré tout les engagements qui sont
fixées par les accords de minsk et parce
que c'est vraiment le pas numéro 1
prioritaire peut il faut se mettre
d'accord sur les conditions pour
régulariser ce conflit pas ce que la
position de l'ukraine étant complètement
inconnu vous n'allez l'a trouvée nulle
part parce que personne ne la connaît
sans attendre
des propositions bien concrète de
l'ukraine
parce que déjà à l'époque en 2020 le
format ne rendit à proposer des
amendements à la constitution projet de
loi et ça fait déjà seize mois depuis ce
temps là au moins il faut que le cren
réagissent si vous êtes d'accord au non
dit non quelque chose
cela contredit toute logique de
régularisation de tous conflits
imaginables et inimaginables
[Musique]
et nous l'avons déjà dit à plusieurs
reprises parce que la pratique
historique de réalisation des conflits
similaires déjà dans les cas apparaît
ici les parties essaient d'arrêter le
conflit ou au monde arrêter les
hostilités les ont les autres déjà au
niveau
quotidien il faut que le sommet d'accord
si on veut vivre dans la même maison il
faut que se mettre d'accord sur les
conditions de vie de coexistence il faut
arrêter d'abord les hostilités demi si
dans cette situation concrète c'est
vraiment le contraire
pour cette raison nous espérons
qu'aujourd'hui cette logique a été
entendu pour que nous puissions on voit
au moins une quelques réactions dans
quinze jours
agence bloomberg
ça a été annoncé aujourd'hui pendant que
nous étions devant la table parce que
nous avons entendu juste après les
négociations c'est pour ça que pour
l'instant je peux rien commenté
nous avons beaucoup d'initiatives à ce
sujet
il n'aurait beaucoup trop haut
nous avons réussi à couper et je sais
pas ce que a été dans la tête de
monsieur torche à skis ski lamy et dans
ce message dans tous les cas il nous a
pas consultés
mais dans ce contexte à ce qui concerne
les contributions aux accords de minsk
parce qu'à ce sujet même sans parler je
fais si l'initiative de messieurs tortue
akono il ya beaucoup de discussions dieu
fait et comme quoi la russie
soutiendrait les séparatistes et c'est
pour ça que via si aujourd'hui il
yad'autres qui ce qu'ils essaient de
rendre la russie
partis qui participent à ce conflit qui
contredit la vue
la réalité
après la conclusion des accords de nice
car
les discussions à ce sujet qui se tient
qui n'a pas aucun sens parce que ça
vraiment ramène les discussions dans une
impasse à
les accords de misc
parler ni parler des interdictions aux
des consignes équipe être soutenue qui
ne peut pas être se tenir
ni pour lui ni pour personne ni pour la
fédération de russie ni pour les autres
en ce qui concerne le soutien du donbass
au dos le cren
et
si on suit cette logique et comme quake
quel camp se tiendrait quelqu'un c'est
pour ça que c'est vraiment une partie
fautive du non respect des accords de
musique en suivant cette logique dans ce
cas là il faut poser la question acte
dans quel sens il faut se tenir l'autre
partie du conflit c'est surtout
l'ukraine
pour cette raison il faut suivre les
accords
acquis surtout qu'ils sont fixés par les
accords de miss qui en ce qui concerne
le règlement le conflit il faut qu'ils
soient à régler dans ce sens surtout du
point de vue du soutien et les
représentants du donbass et de l'autre
partie de l'ukraine
en parlant de ce soutien dans ce cas là
nous on pourrait éviter le besoin d'armé
est là l'ukraine ne tout d'abord et de
la soutenir dans ce sens là
c'est pour ça que depuis longtemps nous
avons la même position en ce qui
concerne l'interprétation des accords de
minsk et l'identification des raisons
pourquoi il n'y a pas de progrès dans le
règlement de conflits c'est contre utile
et ça ne fait que rendre plus difficile
le processus de négociations et
discussions
logiques comme quoi on pourrait se tenir
cette partie l'autre n'ont pas ça
pourrait contredire les accords de mise
parce que les accords demi ce que ne
prévoit que le règlement pacifique d'une
façon non armé de ce conflit mais si on
tient la position conquois une partie
peut être armé et l'autre partie ne pas
être armé il ne s'agit plus d'un
règlement pacifique parce que s'il
pourrait on pourrait parler vraiment
d'une pression armée sur l'autre partie
de ce conflit
merci à jean sèye novosti
bonjour je présente rien investi j'ai
une question de précision concernant
leur encontre annoncée futur à quel
niveau ce soir réalisé deuxième question
est ce que vous avez discuté le sujet de
semer forme en normandie
la rencontre à berlin serait réalisée au
format des conseillers politiques de
foreman normandie des représentants des
ministères des affaires étrangers par
tradition comme c'est fait depuis de mes
20 ans ce qui concerne le sommet des
leaders du format normandie cette
question n'a pas été discutée
aujourd'hui et je pense que depuis le 17
septembre de l'année précédente elle n'a
jamais été initiée pas c'est qu'il ya
des divergences qui
ne peut pas être résolue pour l'instant
parce que le 17 septembre dernier
c'était la dernière rencontre surtout
ces contradictions ont été identifiés
par des conseillers politiques et des
représentants des ministères des
affaires étrangères pour cette raison
aujourd'hui nous avons eu un dialogue
dans le but est d' exclure ces
divergences
de ce haut niveau de se faire une fois
que les solutions soient identifiés nous
sommes sûrs que les décisions du sommet
précédent du format ne mendie pas c'est
que les bilans de formats normandie à
paris et ils ont
un carnet global mais jusqu'à présent
ces engagements ils sont jamais
respectées si je me trompe pas il ya
juste à peu près 20 personnes qui ont
été échangés entre les deux parties et
après on a fini par nous retrouver dans
l'impasse à parce que surtout la partie
ukrainienne a pas
identifiée n'a pas présenté sa position
et ce qui concerne le sommet su
suivants ont pour un parent ont reparlé
une fois que les bilans du sommet
précédent ce soir et ce une fois
que tous les aspects de droit ensuite
qu'en ce qui concerne le stature au post
conflit en ukraine une fois que ce
statut soit identifié défini déterminé
dans ce qu'elle a nous pourrions passer
à la question de ce sommet surtout il
faut pas oublier la question de des
élections des autorités locales et
municipales et dans certaines régions
anne cren
je pense qu'il faut que je réponde ne
plus rien parce que je pense que la
langue russe est plus compact
agence tass
je me présente avec un autocar et ma
question c'est que si les collègues de
forme en normandie comprennent le non
fondé des accusations lancées contre la
russie sur le la consommation des
troupes aux frontières
de cette question parce que dès le début
nous avons
expliqué à nos collègues et parce que le
règlement un truc indien à l'est de
l'ukraine et surtout les règlements et
la réduction des tensions autour de
l'ukraine
liés de l'otan à l'est il s'agit
d'autres négociations qui sont pas liées
entre elles c'est pour ça que l'escaladé
et qui se manifeste autour d'eux le cren
et dont la désescalade à se trouvera
depuis les décembre dernier une grâce
aux certains représentants de certaines
régions des régions de donetsk de
lougansk est mais le créneau et à se
tenir nous voyons les réductions des
attaques
du donbass mais ce sont des questions
différentes et nous n'avons pas discuté
de ces questions
toutes les manoeuvres qui sont fait à
part la russie sur son propre territoire
et surtout en même temps à part le temps
et les états unis sur le territoire
ukrainien c'est une autre question liées
à la sécurité de la russie on nous
appelle et surtout en tranchée en ce qui
concerne la désescalade mais ça n'a
aucun sens c'est pas tout à fait correct
passé que les accords domicile prévoit
déjà les conditions d'escale à parce que
si on suit cette logique le président
ukrainien et les
pouvoirs dolo ton doivent
annuler les manoeuvres qui prévoit la
participation des milliers de troupes y
aussi beaucoup de matériel de frappe et
d'attac sur le territoire ukrainien mais
nous n'avons pas entamé à discuter de
cette question parce que si on conduit
cette logique il faut désescalade
assurer la désescalade de situation il
faut annuler la loi qui a été adoptée
par le parlement ukrainien en décembre
dernier parce c'est pour ça que pour
l'instant ne faisons que envisager cette
question ce que pour nous c'est
inadmissible parce qu'il ya des
manoeuvres de grande échelle qui sont
réalisés à côté de nos frontières par
nhs les pays qui n'ont aucune liaison
avec le cren et la sécurité de le cren
évidemment nous ne pouvons pas ne pas
prendre en considération ce fait
juste deux dernières questions
pour ce qui de la pression sur l'ukraine
ça n'a aucun sens une pression sur un
état se verra évidemment apparemment
personnes et exerce ce type de pression
sur eux mais je dis encore une fois ça
n'a aucun sens parce que le crâne doit
comprendre où elle même parce qu'il doit
être réglée
arrêter cette guerre
fratricide
parce que surtout
sans appliquer sans respecter du façon
choisie l'accord 2015 qui concerne
l'armement pour ce qui est de cette
question
ça n'a encore liaison avec la question
qui a été discuté et surtout par rapport
à ce qui se passe à l'est de l'ukraine
le conflit doit être arrêté pour que ces
armements qui sont utilisées par les
deux parties ne soit pas attiser dans
cette guerre fratricide
chaîne téva
j'ai proposé ça parce que ça faisait une
jeune fille de euronews je vous ai
reconnu c'est à vous la parole est je
pourrais pas vous quitter sans répondre
à un très belle fille et qui ont mieux
regarde dans les yeux
quelles sont les perspectives de nos
bois formant dit du point de vue de la
russie
est-ce que ce format aux configurations
fonctionnement est ce que vous avez pu
discuter la création d'un mécanisme de
cessez-le-feu
ou la france pourrait prendre part comme
le cren a voulu à ce qui concerne le
format normandie ça fait longtemps que
nous appelons à ce qu'il joue un rôle
positif constructive mais fou pour en
assurer il faut que la russie l'ukraine
et l'allemagne et la france
et la même interprétation des accords de
musique est la même c'est quand des
actions à suivre parce que si je me
trompe pas ça fait depuis l'automne
depuis l'automne 2020
au niveau du groupe est répartie de
contact où nous avons élaboré les
bronzés propositions visant à assurer à
voir la feuille de route où aller de
format normandie
s'est engagé à
préparer ce que ce qu'on appelle des
classes teurs un terme très particulier
mais depuis il n'y a pas
d' influence positive et sur la
résolution de tous ces questions à minsk
a et c'est pour ça qu'aujourd'hui pour
cette raison
nos collègues ont accepté le fait que le
format normandie pourra jamais rouge
jouer un rôle politique pendant
que au format normandie nous ayons des
interprétations différentes des accords
de mise parce que très souvent
[Musique]
nous comprenons même pas
inquiet de caumont qui sont utilisés
sur la base de qe2 que mons qu'on puisse
tirer des conclusions parce que déjà aux
formes en normandie ou aux etats-unis
ils utilisent d'autres types d accord de
miscou des
formes en normandie parce que jusqu'à
présent on nous propose de nous engager
sur le respect des accords de misc par
la russie parce que
le 17 septembre dernier les initiatives
qui était présente et a dû face on a
fini de l'ukraine et qui était soutenue
par l'allemagne et la france
mais ça a été arrêté mais si vous
considérez que la russie c'est la partie
de ce conflit vous pouvez l'écrire
vincent cas là il faut faire la liste
des engagements qui doivent être
respectées par le russe y est et c'est
la question que nous avons posée et on
nous a répondu on connaît pas qui sont
les engagements de la russie dans ce
sens là s'il faut que la russie un vent
elle même ses propres engagements c'est
pour ça qu'à l'issue du sommet précédent
nous avons accepté de réaliser le sommet
avec la participation des lecteurs dépit
de formats normandiez à conditions
et d'avoir une consultation préliminaire
du texte des accords des documents de
formats normandiez à l'époque nous avons
posé la question
de représentant de l'ukraine de la
france et de l'allemagne le 10 17
septembre dernier au monde dit nous on
engagement qui est refusée par le
donbass très souvent on nous appelle à
faire la pression sur le dôme base pour
qu'il respecte les accords de miss mais
chaque fois ils nous disent on s'est pas
dites nous qui sont les engagements qui
sont pas respectés par le donbass passé
que de leur côté ils essaient de faire
tout leur possible
chaque fois que nous posons cette
question on n'arrive pas à avoir la
réponse surtout du point de vue du
cessez-le-feu du poste de contrôle de
passage de
citoyen mais jusqu'à présent ils savent
pas la réponse de l'autre côté parce que
cet inconnu c'est pour ça qu'ils aient
si nous arrivons à trouver la seule même
compréhension des accords de misc pour
que ce soit pas écrit avec du lait
qu'ils soient jamais lu par personne je
pense que dans ce cas là le format ne
mendie pourrait jouer un rôle
déterminant dans le règlement de ce
conflit parce que sinon le format
normandie malheureusement ne pourrait
pas aboutir parce que dans ce cas là et
vous pourrez suivre la logique et la
situation que nous voyons jusqu'à
présent malheureusement de ne pas donner
la parole à l'ats pour la traduction
voire
par match com justement de l'absence
lors de l'application
jamais il y avait quelque chose qui a
été élaboré ensemble partie de vos
contacts
certains
différends après on a commencé la
mauvaise classe terres du parc pasteur
fois il ya eu des divergences ça n'a pas
marché
et donc quand on s'est rendu compte
qu'on semble due forme en normandie a
toujours ses points de divergence qui ne
permet pas de produire un effet positif
est donc aujourd'hui
parce que
se base
dans
exactement
alors vraiment
ce soit alors cette question la france
vous pensez que nous sommes parties au
conflit alors à votre avis quelles sont
vos applications que son engagement est
la réponse ne savons pas ce qui en fait
d'inventer ses propres engagements alors
ne sont pas consommées
le faire justement à
vocation concrète et ceci ne sera pas
possible pas d'accord sur
des musiques une autre question que nous
ils exactement son désengagement des
obligations de
mettre pression massive
de passage mais toutes ces initiatives
sont ignorés
par le hamas alors oui le format
normandie pour exister
et deuxième question
c'est concerne les organismes de
contrôle avec mes participations de la
france et d'allemagne est-ce que vous
avez discuté ce sujet on a pratiquement
même pas discuter de cette question
parce qu'il s'agisse il s'agirait des
propositions fantaisistes parce qu'au
lieu d'avoir un mécanisme opérationnel
pour éviter les attaques les et
bombardements on propose parce que cette
initiative ukrainienne à l'époque parce
que si je me trompe pas
à l'origine ça a été formulée par les
médias même qui sans consultation avec
la france et l'allemagne pour rendre ce
mécanisme en club de discussion
[Musique]
pour qu'on puisse avoir une sorte de
club de discussion à côté de la ligne du
cessez le feu pendant
que des débordements ou des attaques
continuerait parce que deux
d'après
les accords
du 22 juillet 2000 20 heures parce qu'à
l'époque c'était bien écrit que chaque
fois les deux parties doivent réagir
dans le but d'éviter le feu le tir et à
l'époque on avait le cessez-le-feu
pendant deux mois et demi ou
les crèmes dessert retirer mais si je me
trompe depuis le 23 décembre dernier
concours on est revenu à ce mot de
cessez le feu et en reparlant de
désescalade
en ce qui concerne l'augmentation des
participants
comment ici on dit chez nous plus de
monde - d'oxygène mais y'a poids de bus
vont de déployer et d'entamer des
discussions diplomatiques
à hong kong en essayant de comprendre de
quoi il s'agit de quel type de tir de
fusil s'il faut faire des tilleuls
depuis une buse eu ou non
ce sont toutes les questions qu'il faut
respecter parce que chaque fois
l'ukraine je trouve des prétextes pour
ne pas respecter ses engagements même
des jeunes dans ce contexte à ce sujet
il n'est pas lié avec quoi que ce soit
d'abord il faut arrêter le feu il faut
arrêter les tirs malgré les divergences
des jamais mais sur cette question
chaque fois ils essayent d'inventer
quelque chose pour quelqu'un au lieu de
l'ukraine au lieu du donbass eux
puissent trancher et résoudre cette
question je ne comprends pas cette
logique est aujourd'hui entre autres
nous avons discuté de cette question
mais conquois la réponse est elle à même
de notre côté et personne n'est jamais
revenu à ce sujet on va espérer que
quand même le raisonnable va remporter
la victoire et va prendre le dessus et
chaque fois désolé j'oublie qui a de
toujours une tradition derrière
parti
le 22 juillet est
revenue et ceci permet justement de
réagir rapidement dans les choses
accidentelle
pendant deux mois et demi que ce
mécanisme fonctionne est
tirée
escaladé sans
permis
alors on savait comme on dit aussi
chers collègues merci s'il ya au moins
encore une question avec une tradition
consécutive
je vais rater mon train va demander il
faut après il faut que je sois viré
c'est pour ça que nos deux formes en
normandie j'ai prenant d'un coup une
fois nos excuses mais je propose espérer
vieux né à berlin ces volets j'espère
avoir toujours une discussion
constructive aux formes arrondies parce
qu'aujourd'hui malgré tous nos efforts
nous n'avons pas de résister à vous
démontrer je pense que pratiquement pour
l'instant les progrès et à 0 et désolé
plus armes et et laissez moi partir
travailler merci
merci encore une fois nos excuses désolé